[Musique]
daniel sainte rose francine bonjour
bonjour alain livory bonjour aux
auditeurs de martinique la première et
des spiritains particulièrement alors
vous avez 64 ans vous êtes retraité de
la poste et vous allez mener la liste
alliance des forces spiritaines c'est
votre première présentation en tant que
tête de liste mais vous avez été co
listier de christian valat en 2008 et
dit rick ayotte en 2014
alors qu'est-ce qui qu'est ce qui vous
pousse à vous présenter qu'est ce qui
vous motive mon engagement en général et
suscité par par l'intérêt qu'ils
s'agissent qu'il s'agit d'une mine d'une
mission parce que j'aurais pu être
candidat de ma propre initiative bien
auparavant mais je j'appartenais un
groupe qui s'appelle alliance défaut
spiritaines est donc ce groupe a fait le
constat et l'analyse de la situation de
la commune
sur le saint-esprit et donc il était
nécessaire que nous puissions relever le
défi de de cette phase politique de
transition vient de transition alors
très bien alors de transition pourquoi
vous dites de transition de transition
parce que l'objectif des dernières
élections en 2014 avait poussé le budget
et erika yacht
donc il ya eu de l'impréparation et donc
il n'y a pas eu de projet il n'y a pas
eu dont l'équipe l'équipe en place dans
l'équipe sortante n'était pas préparée
et donc il n'y avait pas de projet
vraiment s'ils voulaient saint-esprit
d'accord on va revenir sur le bilan un
peu plus tard alors vous disiez que vous
étiez donc membre du groupe allianz des
forces spiritaines qui avaient fait un
choix de monsieur pignol et via un
changement en cours que s'est il passé
pourquoi vous retrouvez aujourd'hui tête
de liste
eh bien vous savez monsieur pignol pour
des raisons de professionnel et familial
je crois que quand on va dans une
bataille c'est pour c'est pour aller
jusqu'au bout c'est vers la victoire
donc il était opportun pour lui il nous
a fait comprendre que bon il n'était pas
il n'était pas dans les bonnes
dispositions pour aller jusqu'au bout
donc j'ai été choisi à l'unanimité par
les l'alliance des forces militaires
alors quel bilan tirez-vous du maire en
place
fred michel tyro quel bilan vous faites
de son action depuis 2014
je pourrais faire un bilan si y'avait
s'il y avait bilan je préfère dire que
les saint-esprit les spiritains sont
devenus des nomades et donc comment dire
qu'est ce que vous dites nous met ça
veut dire si on ne reste pas je vais je
vais imagé et vous allez comprendre
le saint-esprit l'investissement public
y en a pas donc il n'y a pas
d'attractions pour le privé un exemple
très simple le saint-esprit et il n'y a
plus de commerces et donc toutes les
activités pratiquement toutes les
activités
au saint-esprit ce sont des activités de
services vous avez trois cabinets
d'infirmières vous en avez autant de
médecins
vous avez trois structures de pompes
funèbres et vous avez un hôpital qui va
certainement fermés et un laboratoire
qui n'exerce plus dont vous vous voyez
le côté le côté sombre de la ville du
saint-esprit alors comment la rendre
comment grande le saint-esprit plus
attractifs tout simplement on a on a une
exemple la semaine passée il ya eu la
visite de monsieur stéphane bern qui
n'est pas de notre initiative bien
évidemment cela veut dire que nous avons
un patrimoine au saint-esprit à
valoriser et je peux vous dire que si si
vous voyez par exemple la mairie la
mairie qui est l'habitation du maire
c'est à dire que là où il doit être en
sécurité et loi là où il doit il doit
être serein pouponne les décisions bien
excusez moi ça devient difficile
d'exercer dans un tel dans une telle
demeure ses accessoires images
réhabiliter l'image de la commune si
votre habitation
la façade c'est le reflet c'est le
reflet de vous même alors quelles sont
les grandes lignes de votre programme
l'action forte il nous reste 20 secondes
l'action forte que vous pouvez mener
alors l'action faute c'est à dire que la
commune du saint-esprit et traditions
traditionnellement tournée vers la
ruralité l'agriculture un prince un
point important du développement durable
et solidaire et je crois que je parlais
du du le fait que les saint-esprit
soient nomades
il n'est pas normal que les speak qu'on
traverse le saint-esprit pour aller à
l'habitation clément et qu'on ne s'y
arrête pas donc je crois qu'il faut
mettre en valeur ce que nous avons parce
que la ville du saint-esprit ce n'est
pas une ville balnéaire
donc il faut valoriser le potentiel
touristique pour favoriser l'attraction
au saint-esprit
monsieur daniel sainte-rose je vous
remercie
merci cette émission était réalisée par
adele qui kelly
donc